James Baldwin gave us our messy humanity
in all of its vulnerability fragility
destructive fearfulness
and imaginative creativity the folks at
Harlem stage in Columbia in New York
live arts somehow film that James
Baldwin's voice was somehow occluded
from our national public and social
discourse and our discourse around
artists and we felt it wise to revisit
him and think about what that brave
courageous voice might mean for us now
James Baldwin was an American essayist
novelist playwright activist he's a son
of Harlan you know who was writing
reviews for commentary the new leader on
all those big questions the Jewish
Question the Negro problem he got tired
of writing those things and went away
left the country to Paris and we we have
this amazing writer who was so bold to
write a plays poems
you know everything and also played a
huge part in civil rights movement so
there's a whole range of
multidisciplinary citywide engagement
about Baldwin's life and work and in
fact his legacy I came to vol him pretty
early on I came to Baldwin as someone
who was an honor student at John Kenney
High School in the Bronx where I was
reading all these big books and some not
somehow not feeling connected but
somehow James Baldwin stuck with me for
all kinds of reasons and so I've been
reading him now for a long time and have
been involved with the resurgent of all
which Baldwin scholarship that began in
2007 in London when we celebrated the
20th anniversary of his death and since
then there's been this urgency to keep
talking about him among a group of
scholars and writers in the essay and
that that agenda was the safe -
sustained
soul of his country and he said about
doing so with immense eloquent
so we're celebrating brawl in a variety
of ways jake gyllenhaal and column toy
Ben they're gonna be in conversation one
of the reasons that came about it's
important that we get people outside the
gospel outside the regular chorus so
what does it mean that these two artists
readers are in conversation about James
Baldwin and so that's what really
interesting to us and we keep talking to
ourselves so one of the things we like
about Harlem stage partnership and also
working with Bill T Jones in New York
leverage is that we get performers it's
a multidisciplinary conversation so one
of the main features of the entire
year-long festivals that were crossing
disciplines and seeing what's Baldwin
mean to a dancer like Diane McIntyre
Charles Anderson - writer you know like
column and then to an actor like Jake
Gyllenhaal
you